soit 25 à toutes les animaux faxer comme
comme elle l'a dit troc et le froid qui
s'en vient pour la chaleur le sable et
l'air saleh qui pourrait leur en vouloir
et plusieurs nous quitte pour un bon
bout de temps on va revenir à verre
malheureusement on tend confinement
pareil chez nous tu mets mon temps de
faire achaler il faut aussi admettre que
les petits bobos comme les gros sont
plus facilement supportable bien au
chaud parce que y est diabétique les
jeunes de partout puis époque a pas de
porter la
la fois du québec où seul projet le ciel
à l'épicerie et à la formation aux
besoins puis on sort pas la progression
de la coved de chez nos voisins du sud
ne les inquiète pas le moins du monde la
plupart ont des résidences dans des
communautés qu'ils connaissent bien ils
sont rassurés puis j'ai appelé l'aborder
dépasse en effet naissance y disent que
le monde dans les centres d'achat ça se
protège mettre leurs museaux et protège
l'épineuse question des couvertures
d'assurance semble même résolu les
assureurs ont ajusté leurs plans pour
tenir compte de la coved depuis un
certain temps déjà des compagnies
aériennes offrent aussi des forfaits qui
incluent une protection avec le vol
d'air canada il nous donne à 21 jours
avec une assurance puis en assurance en
sort plus avec notre assurance des
experts en voyage recommande toutefois
de bien s'informer de bien lire les
petits caractères et d'avoir une
couverture qu'ils soient suffisantes
c'est fallait kelly complications pour
quelqu'un qui qui tomberaient malades à
destination le 120 dollars aux états
unis par exemple il n'ya pas que
l'assurance qui soit indispensable le
véhicule également des compagnies de
transport propose toujours de livrer
celui ci devant la porte du panda québec
et c'est yvan de monter en fleuret dames
apporte une porte qui n'aura pas besoin
d'être déneigés cet hiver ici louis de
belleval radio canada montréal